[Musique]
bonsoir baratte en khâgne à merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
est ce que on peut parler clairement
aujourd'hui une épidémie totalement hors
de contrôle au royaume uni c'est triste
à dire mais effectivement nous ne
contrôlons plus l'épidémie le nombre des
cas augmente les hôpitaux se remplissent
rapidement même si l'on sent pas encore
tout à fait rempli et c'est une période
très préoccupante alors on voit que le
gouvernement n'hésite pas à agiter le
chiffon rouge et dur s'il tombe viol et
le confinement coûte des vies clairement
il y a du mal pour les britanniques à
respecter les règles c'est vrai qu'on a
vu certains reportages on ne voit pas
forcément les en v porté de masques dans
la rue
la prise de conscience n'est pas arrivé
aux dirigeants et aux hommes des femmes
politiques n'ont pas goûté à très
stricte sur ce point ils n'ont pas été
assez sérieux sur la communication d'un
message très simple pour porter votre
masque protégez vous gardez vos
distances
c'est simple message n'ont pas été
transmis à ce rapidement
et c'est comme les petits enfants ainsi
on ne les aide pas correctement alors il
est plus difficile de le faire plus tard
car non le confinement et qu'il
respectait aujourd'hui au royaume uni
l'avis du médecin vous êtes de
l'affection longue
malheureusement nous ne demandons pas
aux gens de rester à la maison et
pourtant c'est une nécessité il faut
rester chez soi et ne sortir que pour
des raisons très importante
ça nous a vraiment un
confinement pour ainsi dire et comme il
s'agit d'un semis confinement il le rend
plus difficile à deux essais le nombre
des cas donc le confinement du rebond
beaucoup plus longtemps car il n'est pas
totale alors là on vient de parler
évidemment des mesures de restriction
mais enfin l'une des causes de cette
épidémie qui n'est pas contrôlée au
royaume uni c'est aussi ce variant ce
variant anglais dont on parle beaucoup
c'est véritablement une épidémie dans
l'épidémie avec ce nouveau variant les
personnes contaminées relâche beaucoup
plus de pathogènes de particules virales
et caressant rejette beaucoup plus alors
le virus est beaucoup plus contagieux
donc nous avons une augmentation du
nombre de cas car il est plus facile de
se faire contaminer
c'est là qu'a failli notre mesure de
contrôle de la contamination de la
contamination
avec ses défauts et avec sept nouveaux
variants nous avons plus de cas alors
pour bien qu'on comprenne on nous disait
déjà que le premier entre guillemets
virus était extrêmement contagieux là on
nous dit que c'est jusqu'à plus de 50%
voire plus contagieux encore ça veut
dire quoi concrètement baratte kenya que
le virus reste suspendue dans l'air
qu'il est
voilà sur chaque table qu'il a du mal
finalement à partir des surfaces qu'on
comprenne bien ya ce taux varie
goodstein c'est une excellente question
mais tout d'abord ce que cela signifie
et qu'il n'y a plus de virus et comme il
ya plus de virus en circulation autour
d'une personne infectieuses alors il ya
plus de chances d'être contaminés et
effectivement ils restent plus longtemps
un temps les airs donc il y a plus
d'aéroport et effectivement il est plus
présent partout la plus dans les airs il
n'a plus sur les surfaces il y en a plus
en général c'est très vrai on attend
beaucoup évidemment des études
britanniques sur le recul qu'on a de ce
variant vous êtes les champions du
séquençage notamment sur le côté
pathogènes on nous dit jusqu'à présent
qu'il n'est pas plus dangereux
ce variant est ce que vous confirmez
encore à ce jour que c'est bien le cas
oui tout à fait la bonne nouvelle c'est
que ce virus n'est pas plus virulente
malheureusement il n'est pas non plus
moins virulent et je souhaite rajouter
une autre bonne nouvelle c'est que je
suis extrêmement certain que le vaccin
fonctionne sur l'ancien variant comme
les nouveaux variants car ce vaccin
reconnaît la protéine de spicules temps
son ensemble et non pas certes un petit
élément qui aurait pu être modifié avec
cette mutation on est content d'entendre
des bonnes nouvelles on va pas on va pas
se mentir battant qu'il ya une autre
éventuelle bonne nouvelle je sais pas si
vous allez nous l'a confirmé
jce britannique neil ferguson qui est un
petit peu fait parler de lui
voilà un petit peu sulfureux mais mais
bref c'est quand même un professeur de
l'imériale collège nous annoncer
aujourd'hui qu'ils qu'il pense que l'on
pourrait déjà avoir atteint l immunité
de groupe et que l'épidémie se terminera
en autant d'aces que vous partagez cet
avis optimiste de ce professeur de
l'impérial collège un autre show et la
base je ne suis pas certain que londres
est atteint à l'immunité de groupe car
il faut un taux d'immunisation de plus
de 60 à 70% et à partir de ce moment
seulement peut-on parler dignité
collective
je ne pense pas que nous nous soyons
déjà à ce niveau
cependant avec les mini station et le
nombre élevé de contamination dans le
pays
on peut espérer que d'ici au début de
l'automne
60 à 70% de la population aura été
immobilisé suite à une contamination ou
suite à une vaccination
merci bharat ingénieur expert en
maladies infectieuses à l'université
d'exeter en direct du royaume uni pour
vu de l'extérieur ce soir merci à vous